Cameron ordis knew the consequences of
telling Canada's secrets that's what the
judge said in his sentencing and ortis
will pay for those consequences 7 years
in jail we thought this conduct was
deserving of a sentence that far
exceeded the sentence imposed by the
trial judge the crown wanted 28 years
minus time served Mr Cameron ortis
betrayed the
RCMP he betrayed our domestic
intelligence part ERS Mr Cameron ortis
effectively compromised the trust that
Canada has earned Justice Robert marage
also called it a betrayal but thought 28
years was too harsh despite agreeing
ordis violated his position of extreme
trust and that his actions potentially
put lives at risk ortis was arrested in
2019 for trying to sell classified
information to a cyber criminal and
suspected moneyer Wanderers at the time
he was one of the highest ranking
civilian members of the RCMP he had
access to some fairly highly classified
technical information on Communications
and Communications intercepts so did he
do damage yes I'm sure he did the judge
called ortis somewhat of an enigma
Witnesses described his work ethic and
intelligence Michael kovrig one of the
two Michaels jailed in China was a
friend and sent a letter of support to
the judge the defense had argued for no
jail time and now plans to appeal
obviously disappointed uh we were hoping
to have a significantly lower sentence
but I understand where Justice M came
from he was given a difficult task to
choose between two very different
extremes while the trial is now over the
judge says Canada's reputation may never
recover saying that oris's actions
undermine Canada's credibility among its
five eyes intelligent sharing Partners
since Oris had access to their secrets
as well teria is Global News Ottawa